well the meantime there is another sign
las vegas is slowly getting back to the
live entertainment our city is known for
this weekend two major sporting events
will have fans in the stands for the
very first time in
seven long months hector mejia is live
at allegiant stadium which will welcome
spectators tomorrow night for the first
time hi hector
hey there alex good morning las vegas is
aiming to become not only the
entertainment capital but also the
sports capital of the entire world and
we'll try to claim that crown
when the first fans stream into a legion
stadium tomorrow on halloween
and they'll be watching the big rivalry
football game between unlv
and unr state health officials approved
a plan for
3 percent of the stadium's capacity that
turns out to be
two thousand fans there will be sections
of 250 people or less
at least 25 feet apart and fans are
required to wear masks
and stay in their designated section
even for restrooms
as you can imagine two thousand tickets
were snatched up fast by long
time season ticket holders and donors
that won't be nearly the crowd the team
hoped for
for the battle for the fremont cannon
but new head coach marcus arroyos says
he'll just take what he can given the
circumstances
we all wish that thing was packed out
and read this weekend but
i'll also take what i can take you're
going to find out i'm a pretty eternal
optimist
we looked around on secondary ticket
websites but could not find
anyone selling their chance to be the
first fans inside allegion stadium
and if you are one of the lucky 2 000
people unlv says
absolutely no tailgating allowed they
also asked fans to arrive early
the gates will open 90 minutes before
kickoff reporting live outside allegion
stadium hector mejia
8 news now